hi everybody it's me grace Helbig and
today on this episode of not too deep we
have V one the only the always Mitchell
Davis he's here again and again and
again and I cannot get rid of him but
he's here for this month of episodes and
I know he wasn't there last month but
that's only because well you'll find out
in the episode so without further ado I
don't know what else you say what do you
say that was better than anything I say
let's just get into this goddamn episode
are you tired of unpredictable color
results discover color & Co the home
hair color personalized just for you by
L'Oreal with color & Co you'll get a
free consultation with an expert hair
stylist who will custom blend a salon
quality shade for your hair needs I mean
you have everything at your dispense
with this guy's I can't even talk I'm so
excited for you to do this no matter
what your hair color goal you can do it
again a free consultation with an expert
hair stylist who will custom blend a
salon quality shade for all your hair
needs and all you have to do is use
promo code grace at color & co.com for
$10 off your first order I was at a
juice place yesterday and like I don't
first of all gross I don't normally do
the whole like extra powders and stuff
for like vegetables and stuff it wasn't
even me that said it it was like my
insides after a week of VidCon I was
like can I give the powder for
vegetables and the powder for protein
and like I could tell even the woman was
like you're ill what's happening more
than this did you just escape like a
kidnapping seriously even when she was
done she was like there's a little
lecture do you want to put it in another
cup and I and literally I could hear my
stomach going yeah way today yeah we
need that now I need to suck on that so
that's where I've been
use that suck on that soundbite for the
promo of this episode please don't leave
me out of context we're rolling suck on
that
suck on that the monthly Mitchell Davis
edition of not sure deep and I tweeted
out four questions
from everyone and saying that this was
our monthly Mitchell Davis episode and
immediately got back monthly except for
June yeah I met we missed one we even
happen we missed one cuz we took some
time off we've got so ahead of ourselves
in episodes we were like literally two
or three months like out that it was
hard to sit down and like talk to people
and then be like well this it but so
they're like can I talk about this thing
that's airing tomorrow I'm like sure but
no one else will hear about it for three
months
that's so real though so we tried to
take it some time off and then get recod
up with everything I just assumed my
episode did so well yeah last time that
you were like we can't have him back
that soon or something bad might happen
or it was so bad that I told Mel to
ghost you anytime you reached out to ask
what my monthly thing I don't respond
Dome is fine I would just slam her phone
onto the ground that's the reality every
time I leave this place I'm like that's
the [ __ ] last one joke was the last
warning record people talk for it oh man
I can't wait till that's actually my
real life I wanted to talk to you about
VidCon yeah yeah cuz I think even though
this will come out later and but I'm so
curious because this was the 10-year
anniversary mm-hmm I was only there for
like six hours in total I mean a blink
one and done but I got to see you for a
moment in time I saw one Pig I saw a pig
sorry but I saw the pig later and now
now is it cool yeah it was a big deal
pickles was great pickles pickles
pickles um slid into my DMS and slid in
with the phrase and I quote Flinx
mmm-hmm
the woman that owns pickles typed out
points I'm sorry in my dance not even
publicly in my DM on Instagram th points
it's cold in here but that warms my
heart I know sorry I wanted to bring the
temperature down a little bit it made my
day it was like then I was like I can
leave I've done my VidCon tents so how
was your big con tankards you've been to
the first one
yeah and now you've been to the tenth
one tenth one a decade of the V cons of
the cons how was it for you it was good
it was it was really cool being able to
like
walk around and if anyone did recognize
me they were just like what the [ __ ] are
you doing it like security I don't think
he should be here he doesn't have a kid
get him out of here no it was it was a
lot of fun though I mean it was they
invited some of the OGS and we all got
to do like a thing at the end I saw the
photo of like the last day and it's like
the greens in you and Buck and like
giant like crazy Olga and like all of
like the feed like right as we were
going onstage so like as soon as we went
up there I was like [ __ ] it it doesn't
matter and we just all started taking
selfies it was that was that warmed my
heart that's the heart of it was but not
to see oh I like I teared up a little
bit when I was walking off I was like oh
wow like it doesn't feel like 10 years
until you do something like that and
you're like yeah this is a family this
is a weird [ __ ] family yeah when I
was seeing all the photos from like Olga
and from my will of DC and people like
that that God will DC was there yeah I
wasn't losers oh my gosh I mean there
was so many I I was like are these
throwback photos no this is everyone at
VidCon right now and it's just like you
remember like I think Olga posted
something that was like cheers to like
all the oh geez that discovered YouTube
before everyone else did before like it
made anyone any money and like really
appreciate it I was like oh someone
tweeted the I can't remember who it was
but it was perfect they were just like
this photo is a great representation of
how the original youtubers were not
pretty we were just people we were just
[ __ ] people who were trying to do
things cause like if you look at you
guys this is you guys ten years later
cleaning yourself up just trying to fit
in and we're still like now it's the
meril twins now worst Anna put her in
the movie yeah but uh ya know that was
one comment that I just [ __ ] lost my
[ __ ] over cuz I was like right in the
center like I feel great this year I
remember like when I decided to like put
makeup on for a video for like this
garbage pail kid
cannot hang mine was the opposite I
remember just feeling like I don't even
God I was like first took off your
eyeliner oh no no no it wasn't even
eyeliner I know in a moment it was it
was when I was I was on the set for this
podcast and someone was like it was your
old makeup artist she was like do you
want me to put something under your eyes
to make it look like you slept last
night and she was being Slyke semi funny
but I was like no seriously couldn't you
do that man and when she did it I I just
remember looking myself in the mirror
and legit being startled but how good
she made me look I would Alma took so
many selfies ever heard John Green
amazing author entrepreneur the founding
father of VidCon and so many other
amazing things he told me once on camera
during an interview for The Fault in Our
Stars that he loves makeup like he just
unapologetically loves makeup and when
he goes on press tourists that's the
thing he loves the most and when he gets
his makeup done he changes shirts and
take selfies in different shirts so he
has photos and talked for later in the
future I'm gonna start doing it so
you're literally doing well beauty gurus
on YouTube do ya you take a bunch of
photos and just different outfits
he's the influencer and the photo
boyfriend he was here I loved hearing
that it gave me such a sense of like odd
permission to care about like oh good
lighting makes a difference and face
powder makes a difference yeah cover
that up just for an hour who gets [ __ ]
no but it was it was fun to see everyone
like did you feel like a sense of like
melancholy at all yeah I mean it was
definitely it was it was like Twilight
Zone II a little bit especially this is
the first year that I went where it was
like I was telling everyone I was like
it's fully padded Viacom VidCon this
year it was very cushioned and very
branded yeah like I was looking at the
booths and I was just like you know I
think that is owned by Viacom and so was
and so ya know hate on that but I'm just
like this is definitely gonna be like a
comic-con thing yeah like there was
people dressed up there was just so many
things happening that even a few years
ago I was like that's not gonna be a
thing here is it right right right it
was a very serious conference like I
could
see people that were just like I'm just
here for the [ __ ] comic books and I'm
like okay first off that's Comic Con and
they don't do that anymore
you're two weeks early yeah and also
this is VidCon but you're it's almost
that so you're right actually your hips
stay right here just all you yeah
exactly
was there anything that you saw what was
your most surprising moment or did you
meet anyone that you're like you were
still shocked to meet in person
I mean I'm I still get really excited
just to see my my the people that I know
you I got so excited see rhettandlink
and just finally just chat a little bit
with those two giants there's two people
that haven't changed they're still like
humblest [ __ ] and the sweetest like
grown men I mean me and Linc every it's
gotten to the point where we don't even
know what to say to each other anymore
we're just making faces at each other
there's like a dad with a baby I've
realized that link is the future me oh
that's a good future you yeah we I just
thought we were looking at each other I
don't know if he got it but that in that
moment he was a little stun I was like
oh that's me
oh god and then he just made this crazy
face and I was like I make that face so
I made it right back at him we weren't
looking in a mirror no that was the
whole thing I should be from this grace
this really happened yeah I know I saw
Michael Buckley and it was just like
pure joy yeah I was so great it was
great seeing Smosh too I just hadn't
hung out with any of them they were
there too yeah I got to hang out with
Ian and Anthony oh that's cool yeah it
was just a lot of fun chatting with Shay
was so fun like you know she was there
there's some people that I miss that I
was like dang it yeah and honestly like
Olga I mean the first year that I went
to VidCon she randomly I ended up
getting too drunk and staying in her
house and she gave me like this giant
like I swear it was just a blanket with
a hole cut in it for for your head game
that was like those are your pajamas and
I was like Olga what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
yeah I remember I think it was my first
or second bit kind you and I were
drinking maybe with Jaret whiskey in my
hotel room and then we were like let's
go down to the lobby bar that's where
everyone is and old it was the first
person that I saw we took like a shot
and left the room and then went down to
the lobby bar and all goes the first
time we bumped into off the escalator
and I hugged her and she just leans into
me she goes you smell like whiskey that
sounds yeah she's Russian I like your
Irish she was just like you smell like
whiskey and in front of like everyone
and I was like Shh shush shush it's good
to see you too I know she's just like
well-intentioned then I was like oh god
I smell like whiskey I need to I need to
get away from the elevators I miss your
juggling the socks I love the socks I
love me some moosh walks she's so good
at juggling that I know is really circus
it's crazy but that's so fun you got to
see oh and I'm so glad that like
everyone went yeah you know that wanted
to go and it was cool that they got the
picture before they Fano snapped us away
like bring it in the musically kids -
tik-tok errs where all the sudden
they're breakdance I saw Tyler Oakley
retweet this thing that says when they
ask me why I'm not at VidCon this year
and it's just someone going to tick
stalkers seem to have broken out into a
dance battle looking thing and you know
what's crazy is okay two teenagers that
dance like me yes think that they're
like amazing my okay so my friend Emily
was like why are they doing this without
any music and I was like cuz they're
tick tock errs they want to add it in
later it is I would have had a
full-blown panic attack if I had seen
that in real life
google it there was a circle in the
front in the heat one of them's around
like a sweatshirt it's crazy
circle people also look like they don't
know why they can't look away from this
terrible thing that's happening in front
of them yeah I felt like that was the
VidCon moment it well they mamrie and I
were in the car pre-meeting pickles the
pig which was truly the highlight of my
VidCon small window of experience we
were in a car with
fifteen year old and timothydelaghetto
and we were like catching up with him
being like you're done Wilin now how was
that like you're married now what's
going on just have a normal adult sweet
conversation for the brief moment in
time they were driving back to the hotel
and this 15 year old in the back just
kept trying to insert himself into the
conversation and we're talking about
podcast he's like papi you do guys do
podcasting I I listen to I have a voice
I listen he just kept saying and then he
said he listens to impulsive the Logan
Paul thing yeah he's like I listen
impulsive you guys like impulsive and
mainly this goes not my cup of tea and
they trying so hard he goes why not why
not and she's like she's and she's
trying with all of her self-control to
not like verbally abuse this child
I just wanted to turn around go not my
favorite youtuber he's like I think it's
funny I mean and then he's talking to
this like British 19 year old next to
him and the British kids like yeah
podcasts are where all the money is at
and it gives like if my manager says
that I need a new pocket
I'll do a podcast and then the guy like
introduced himself and the 19 year old
was the 15 year olds talent manager and
I wanted to throw myself out of the
moving car immediately but then we fight
thank [ __ ] god that like there is a
God that intervenes as soon as we got
out of the car this big ass pig came in
front of us and I was like Pig get out
of my face tiny terrible I want this pig
right now now I mean that just goes back
with what I'm saying like well that was
it was it's different that's different
now I think that was my last month it
was a different it was a different
environment yeah like people are
starting for very different reasons to
do things and it's and it's it's lots
lots of kids i retweeted I tried walls
during VidCon i retweeted this like
David Bowie clip of him being like think
I said david dobrik come on no David
David Bowie where he was just talking
about who's like if you're making
anything for the concept of money it's
already has a taint on top it's already
bad yeah like there's already a concept
of it's fake and yeah yeah I definitely
hey that's cool that Barbie vlogs hey
you know what more power to her she only
vlogs in her room I found out wait this
is the doll yes yeah I took pictures in
her home oh I walk before oh yeah and
they were like you take pictures from
Barbie vlogs normally and I was like yes
she does she log in there but don't get
me wrong it was a cool house and the
table flipped from breakfast to dinner
but it was it was there was definitely
some winter toy yeah okay so this
introvert Barbie it's like the new brand
hey I'm gonna be real with you I could
definitely see us being replaced by just
AI things like a Barbie and I'm just a
Ken doll in this I think half of the
things that were at VidCon were AI yeah
they tend to make shipping apart at the
end it was just peace I didn't see the
pig after that it came on the jet plane
hi pickles Instagram it flew on a plane
to get there so it's got a brother
that's a French Bulldog named deal so
there dill pickles oh my god sorry I
mean pickles I'm just fully like
promoting everything that you're about
because I'm treating on the podcast
pickles that was my favorite young
creator to me at VidCon this year living
with pickles that was awesome ya know
when I saw your picture I freaked out
and like turned to like the three people
there was just three random people near
me and I was like do you know where this
pig is literally they're like Mitra you
gotta cool it on these drinks I'm like
it's only a no no seriously there's a
pig here I met I met pickles the pig and
the bartender at the lobby bar said he
remembered me from last year and that
was I was like I can never come back I'm
officially I was hardly here last year
first of all I'm a marine I went
downstairs at 11:20 before our meet and
greet and the bar wasn't open till 11:30
so we brewed those [ __ ] that found
the corner to sit in and stare at the
bar until it opens oh man we sat down
the guy just goes I remember you from
last year and I was like stop that's not
okay and then we did our meet and greet
and then we came back and had a drink at
the bar afterwards and the guy was just
like back for more I remember just goes
shut up
babies like being playful and let you
mean it was like I'm sorry
we're not friends and I realize that
probably terrible how was your meet and
greet I mean you're illiterate it was
fun it's now you know it's like ten
years later someone you're talking to
everyone they're like I watched you in
like middle school and now I just
graduated college just to like that's
cool it's cool I haven't changed at all
there's a lot of like it's very sweet
and fun to see people that have like
been around for a long time and then
also people that are like it's okay if
you want to like you seem tired what
take a break I don't think I'm like oh
is this now embarrassing for me to keep
showing up like should I call it
I definitely ya know this is the first
time where like I always joke about
internet years being like dog years but
I was like no no I'm right you guys all
think I'm a hundred like I walked around
the floor and went to the Nickelodeon
thing oh yeah and I I genuinely was like
people are looking at me like I'm sick
like I'm watching someone like you're a
narc like I'm like I'm watching like I'm
like there to be like be careful Timmy
don't watch em close to the good burger
car I'll explain that later what it was
I felt like I was like 10 years old
no no I'm 10 years old I mean online you
had another's here I'm a hundred baby
yeah it was the most depressing thing to
say other than that's a fun question to
think about that no the most depressing
thing was the fact that I didn't get in
up I brought trunks I was ready to get
in the pool oh I thought you said I
thought you're talking about and you
made a nickname up for a drug I don't
know I brought I brought chunks no no I
literally kept telling myself I was like
this last VidCon I'm finally gonna get
in that goddamn pool that I've seen so
many times and I didn't I still didn't
and I'm like that was my last chance
just jump over the fence now I've got
these perfect short shorts that were red
that I used to wear for these old videos
called short shorts of Mitchell Davis I
still
I was like I'm just gonna go downstairs
with the red towel and these red shorts
and I had it planned it was in my bag I
just forgot I just totally forgot so
like that was honestly my downfalls I
was like I just want to be live
Louisville live walking through the main
hall just being like have you guys seen
the pool like out a reject from Baywatch
just the Chris Farley from Baywatch it
just being like seriously I think I'm
really far from it that was like what I
wanted to do and I I just got so into
everything else that all sudden I was
like [ __ ] it's over I missed it yeah
okay I mean here's an in ten more years
she'll get down there I know we've all
been using that [ __ ] face app already
know what I'm gonna look like oh that
face up I was gonna say did you use your
face up and then just turn into link
like I did it and I turned into my
grandpa at the edge of a bar going hey
I'll buy you tell me that story later
I'm like the moment it changed I was
like ooh that guy's from Ohio [ __ ] like
That's not me
yeah it was me but that's so I've been I
haven't done it I've seen people do it
to photos of myself but it's always it
just freaks me out that we're obsessed
with like Future past and that like
everyone's obsessed with like the baby
faces - yeah no I did a gender swap I
did the I did like younger and then that
younger picture I did younger again and
it's all my Twitter and then the old I
did old old - old three and by old three
I look like at the end of Beetlejuice
when they're there on the table and
their clothes that they were married in
that's what you look like three times
through it's crazy and then three times
young your teeth just get huge you just
look like Austin Powers baby I
there's no I don't understand because I
don't think any outcome of going younger
or older is gonna make you feel good
about your current self ya know the
first younger one I looked at and I was
like that doesn't look like I did
anything that just looks like what I
know I look like like I look that good
all the time and then I you know you
press your finger you see
undo itself and you're like okay yeah
that's new but you know what but that's
basically that's all that's what I'm
texting that makeup artist to get out
all the sudden I'm like remember when
you said you could do that thing where
you make me look good in real life yeah
maybe you do that every day and it's
just a thing we have yeah called me
wearing it that day you just put makeup
on every day I should have wore makeup
today I'm sorry
hey now Dario we're gonna take a break
see if it's chance to put on some
goddamn under-eye concealer and then
we'll be back with more monthly ish
Mitchel uh not too deep do you have any
III don't have any in my back trunks no
just can see if there's something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help online counseling can help
they offer licensed professional
counselors who are specialized in issues
like depression anxiety relationships
trauma anger family conflicts LGBTQ
matters grief self-esteem and more you
can connect with your professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment and you can get help on your
own time at your own pace everything you
share is confidential it's also so
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist and if for some
reason you're not happy with your
counselor you can request a new one at
anytime for no additional charge and
best of all it's truly affordable and
you will get 10% off your first month
with the discount code grace so why not
get started today go to better help calm
slash grace fill out a questionnaire to
help them assess your needs and get you
matched with the counselor that you'll
love that's better help calm slash grace
yeah you got to do a tongues once you
know if you don't drop chunks at least
once in your life what you doing you're
never gonna see God in the right way it
opens your mind it expands your soul a
tux
I think someone slipped you something
done it ate tux before I came here
did you rice your balls after beans did
you go to the after parties at VidCon we
have we started is there going again
there we go
are we doing ethically okay I wasn't
sure like you just saw I wasn't sure I
was like I'm gonna hold it it's just
it's very we've rolled right into it
okay and see did you go to the after
parties at VidCon um yeah a few of them
yeah yeah yeah I did
the last one I whoo it was a it was a
doozy I danced for like two hours like I
went down there and did the thing like a
alphaCAT actually I was on his in story
because he was like he actually like
zoomed in on just like a crazy me
dancing in the wild as I get it Mitchell
I guess I did not know that he filmed
that dancing like everyone was watching
uh and that's the thing is this party
that's the setup I wasn't even paying
attention to it is it was like there was
a floor and then every time they had the
lights bump you realized that there was
just like a balcony of people watching
you dance but I was just so into it that
uh I guarantee you I'm gonna get it I'm
already need a message a few people get
some videos on my channel I'd like to
see this footage cuz I mean I was just I
was going for yeah I mean it's your
ten-year anniversary I literally I kept
telling myself that so many times I was
like it's been ten years I thought I
don't give a [ __ ] you know it was just
like and there was just a couple Kanye
songs I was like okay here we go got you
in all the fields in the right side my
hips is movin I have ass don't lie they
can and it was it was pretty crazy
that's the one thing I did not feel bad
about missing at all are the after
parties oh yeah I mean they definitely
have their own style of after-party yeah
this I went to the the ones that weren't
like the one the main one I always went
to the one that like someone was hosting
that was like okay those like that was
the studio71 that I was talking about
that was really fun but the mixer things
there was no one in there really yeah
like no one went to them like the first
year when those were like the main thing
yeah
yeah it was just like everyone was like
could you find better things to do and I
was like okay like I remember walking in
and just being like okay goodbye
and then just turning back around cuz
that was so loud and there was just yeah
no one in there oh that's it that's a
tough environment to infiltrate this day
well especially because right next door
there was just like the the lounges in
the back are getting so elaborate
beautiful and crazy I don't know how
long you get did you even get to I
didn't I didn't even dabble with there
was a lounge that looked like the
[ __ ] jungle I went into it that was
like a rehab side did we just go out too
and then I looked up I was like no cuz
there's [ __ ] chandeliers like they
also had like their own thing going on
and it was just there's just so many
things happening now like don't get me
wrong there's a part of me that's so
[ __ ] grateful and excited to be like
look how real this is all day yeah yeah
but at the same time I'm also like not
super for me it's not like the same
thing nobody cuz I remember there used
to be just like the maker party was the
big one that everyone wanted to get into
and it was so funny when we had Alex
Clark on the podcast animator that I'm
like we didn't know each other he's like
you smuggled me into a maker studio
party at VidCon like five six years ago
I was like I bet I did sir
hey those are the nights to be alive
when you do real runaround from ballroom
to ballroom and see if you have the
right wristband and how you can get your
other friends into this these parties
that you just no one's there to like
meet anyone everyone's just there to get
hammered yeah cuz it was an open bar
yeah I've been there and I even win it I
was like is this an open bar and they
were like yes and I was like wow but uh
cuz you know that just means like maybe
we should stop by but no it was it was
an empty little room the kids are too
cool yeah cool for the party scene I
know you're old when you're like I'm
showing up for the open bar no okay yeah
in fear yeah literally I was just like
like it was a scary moment like first
second I was like checking the clock
like did I okay no it's been open for an
hour and a half okay yeah I'm not that I
didn't show up before it opened well I
guess I'm too cool for this you back
I pranked you guys you guys thought I
wanted to come be at your party yeah
right yeah right okay Mitchell as
everyone knows by now or should know
that these episodes are very
free-flowing
yes we rant we laugh we rant we laugh we
love we cried we experienced every ounce
of emotion possible available to us in
our limited spectrum of emotion Wow I
stopped just to see where you'd take it
and you took it to a beautiful place
sorry I was reading what's trending on
Twitter I was looking at an
inspirational quote on Instagram I don't
know but I asked for some Twitter
questions just to see where the
conversation takes us and someone says
how long have you gone without drinking
which I realize I thought this was
something in reference to like did you
take time off from drinking no question
yeah I mean if anything this VidCon was
the first VidCon where I was like I'm a
hang out at that bar downstairs yeah I
actually do it and like to the point
where I wasn't even getting like drinks
anymore I was just like can you just
give me as much risk as you kind of mix
so the love about a bubbly whisky and
soda that I literally did two of those
at the end of it into one night and I
was just like they don't even taste like
anything and I was like what the next
day I was like they definitely hated
like so with the thing in there but yeah
it's seriously even the bartender was
like you sure you want that and I was
like yeah man yeah yeah just just do it
look like the kind of guy doesn't know
anyone I'm a 10 year baby over here to
your life how long you make youtuber hmm
you know I'm talking about [ __ ] you did
you remember vine seriously let's talk
about vine bartender okay so you know
you two look like a party you could be a
bartender in a movie I would know that
cuz I'm I'm
in a movie so I never been in a movie
I'm kidding the face for a bartender if
you've got a bartender I just pulled
them front of this mic off like it you
hooked out yeah I'm so sorry
you're drunk on power from Vic content
good lord
oh my speaking of drunk someone s
described the other person what the
other person is like drunk in three
words or phrases oh I think we should do
one back and forth like yeah I'm trying
to think of my three should I go first
yeah go for it
spicy goofy funny slightly paranoid
clumsy also close I love drunk Mitchell
because you get drunk and loose and then
you have like a moment of being like am
I too drunk right now always every time
then you'll let it go and then you'll go
on again one sec yeah once I pass that
home it's weird
initial hump where you get like two
drinks and you're like I feel it okay is
everyone else feeling it you're not
alone okay now I'm gonna save space and
now I can go literally the last time we
hung out at that that freaking tiki bar
I was like mine limits like two and a
half drinks and not you were like what
tricky one I was like baby and you're
like oh he did it he dipped to win he
that's my favorite Mitchell and it's
like then you just go yeah like I was
hanging out on the patio
I didn't even smoke I'm just hanging out
there it's freezing and I'm just like
yeah there's a breeze we're not inside
that's crazy like that Mitchell was out
and he was ready to go that dude stop
that Mitchell walk to a taco stand after
while everyone else left I was like I'm
just gonna keep walking do you remember
that I remember I remember leaving with
Elliot and having the mom moment of fear
of being like Mitchell we just left him
alone I don't know if he can actually
get home by himself I definitely need to
like let go and be like he's an adult I
don't need to like take care of him
I'm gonna see if I get a phone call in
the middle of the night that like
Mitchell's been found in a ditch subway
I woke up with the full extra burrito in
my face it was amazing I had one there
and I must have got one for me the next
day
that's one of my he was a good guy that
night yeah you did you really looked how
fierce I did that's the one time in New
York
when I lived in Brooklyn that I stumbled
home from like day drinking with a
friend that had just gone through a
breakup and it was like we just tied one
on and then I came home I picked up a
tiny ironing board on the way home I was
like I need this on the street and then
I got back and two different delivery
people from GrubHub showed up at my door
at the same time because I forgot that I
ordered something hello gentlemen I had
ordered like meals for like a family of
six from very [ __ ] up
try guys episode blue like the next
morning when I looked around at the
battleground that I had waged on my
human effects giving you by I was like I
can't believe I got back here last night
let alone acquired all these treasures
it was I was like proud and ashamed at
the same time I was like I'm not gonna
tell this story for like a year yeah I'm
gonna let this sit for a second cuz if I
tell people this right now they're gonna
be like are you okay yeah the last
episode when I finally broke that new
pants shooting story oh yeah I was like
how do you be had to be six months
before I could say that or it's just not
okay like cuz it cuz even a few of my
friends were like you finally told it
you told the story that's like yeah I
had I I finally felt comfortable if it
was finally a joke in my mind I'm better
than
like that's so real though like when you
do something like that you're like
there's a there's like a period of shame
or no one can know I know this will be
funny but right now this looks like a
cry for help like I can't be by myself
yeah and we also can never tell okay
someone last thoughts on all the
live-action Disney remakes I mean what
do you have a strong opinion either way
not super I mean don't get me wrong I'm
excited to listen to Beyonce and
childish gambino yeah Donald Glover
singing those songs like that's gonna be
so freakin fun yeah honestly this is
just wait this is a way for the new
generations to get reintroduced to the
things that we love and let's be honest
they're already like such intensely good
movies that I'm like why not if anything
they're just gonna be like that sucked
let me watch the original yeah and
that's kind of cool right yeah I guess
I'm looking around the room like this
here you get what I'm saying audience at
home yes we do it's also a way for
Twitter to just get upset about casting
yeah it's really it's like any time they
announce that there's gonna be a new
live action of anything I'm like oh
here's just a new way for people to be
mad on either side about anything about
this I like how it's gotten to the point
though where it's almost the casting is
almost a joke like they said Little
Mermaid and then like two days later
Terry Crews was like I need to play
Sebastian and then he's like he just
it's just like a video of him being like
undersea see that like and he's just
like I'm Terry Crews and I should be
smashing it I think this I I'm James
like on Twitter like literally I was
like is this a joke is this for real is
he being fun is but I was like honestly
though Terry Crews should be Sebastian
so for sure but it was awesome like he's
just he was so happy in the video and I
was just like this is where we live now
where you can just audition live on
Twitter yeah and and now the audience is
gonna vote for if it happens
Terry cares the the the headline is
Terry Crews knows he'd be perfect as
Ariel's dad in the Little Mermaid Ariel
dad yeah see I wasn't sure I thought it
was Sebastian or the but oh yeah he he
tweeted out a photo of him photoshopped
as a dad dad but I'm telling you the
under-the-sea video unless I crazily
made that up you might have had some
trunks and then no no no sir Terry Crews
singing under the seat I'm telling you
that happen this is a conspiracy
didn't Terry you got a DM me you had a
very vivid dream well and also I got a
real good idea oh yes
Terry Crews on Twitter singing audition
under the sea yes July 9th this came out
it's just mom brought me such joy but I
was like this is her he's got some
bubbles around him and it looks like
he's just in the front of a random
apartment yeah yeah it was like hey can
you film this for a second and the guys
like these are you Terry Crews and he's
like wait a second see my pecs are
better my Triton is bigger take it from
me need a refresher watch a GT yeah he
plugged his own show and use his
audition which also is a new thing I'm
gonna start doing I mean going for
something like have you seen live lava
TV from me okay what was the audition
about yeah I'm supposed to be crying I'm
sorry I I mean I need him to be hired as
my social media marketing manager now if
he gets this role you gotta have him on
and only talk about that [ __ ] yeah you
only talk about things have them on
period oh yeah I'm talking about
anything he wants to talk about gosh
nothing I'll sit in silence for just a
few five minutes let him sing just for
55 minutes move his pecs in the camera
oh my god I love it
just ASMR Peck like Terry's are called
Peck dancing I know you're listening hon
Oh like I don't have a chance but you do
honey
down this thing to my solitaire I love
Terry Crews it's big business
I'm not following what a [ __ ] idiot I
am like he like there's a there's an
episode on America's Got Talent where he
click the button once he was like no no
his story was too good he deserves it
and ran down there and pushed it and I
was like yeah Jerry you take over the
[ __ ] show it's your show Terry it see
the host of it yeah but he's definitely
not one of the judges but he made it
happen for that guy judge but yeah he
touched that gold button and I was like
you do it Terry he was at the Shorty
Awards that mamrie and I went to he's so
lucky New York it confirmed our fevered
dream you were sitting at the table in
front of us memories goes left Terry
Crews he seems so much genuine and he
was having the best damn time I've ever
seen someone have at an event it was
amazing because Brooklyn nine-nine won
like a shorty award because sure the
Shorty Awards represent all that the
Internet has to offer like my vision
shows my favorite YouTube channel it's
great but have you seen Aladdin I
haven't watched any of the new ones
sanur you ready yeah there's there's the
big baldra I haven't even seen them
because I remember the old ones and I
said there was a lot of seeing in them
and I'm not a big music these are good
how much singing I saw Aladdin very high
in 3d and there was a lot of wrong
choices made gonna say I already counted
three too much to handle and then when
will Smith popped out and his chest was
just blue and giant I was like I can't
handle this I can't handle like swatting
yeah I'm like completely down to watch
them but only if they're like the rental
special on iTunes or whatever for that
week like I'm gonna watch them that way
yeah but I'm not gonna pay I mean going
to the movies is so [ __ ] expensive
already my prop card I need my peanuts
in my shoulder and I just did no it's
like no I mean it's just so expensive
and unless you're like a super like I
got a
see this I'm not a Disney person I mean
it's not made for us yes the thing too
is but a lot of my peers they are
obsessed I feel like there's two types
of people people that are like whatever
about Disney the people that are that's
the like religion yeah they have to take
it in and digest it and then either [ __ ]
on it or love it yeah but I mean that's
just like I feel like that's just like
the culture of the Internet these days
you just they just want to take it in
and either [ __ ] love it it's our
favorite thing or be like this is why
it's the worst right yeah so well on
that uplifting message about the
Internet let's take one more break let
me get back more with monthly ish
Mitchel not today dude I can't was just
use some rapid-fire rapid-fire okay well
we don't have a ton of great questions
no offense y'all okay let's talk about
someone said would you raid area 51 with
grace yes have you I just got caught up
on this area 51 business I was I was so
invested even at VidCon I was trying to
tell people and they were like you're
crazy and I was like you got a Google
this man yeah and I had time has come
there's all these um meet the guy behind
the area 51 page he's terrified of what
he's created
I mean it's these median and just
reported it it's gonna happen these
people are going to like even if they're
like no I'm not gonna actually do it was
a joke like for every one of those
there's another one that's like I'm
going yeah and yeah it's uh it's gonna
be an event I'm very excited you're
gonna go I don't I don't think I'm gonna
go but I'm gonna watch you're gonna
watch it go down yeah I'm saying that
did you hit except like I'm going on the
Facebook page maybe alright oh no I lied
on Facebook I'm the first one
don't get me Zuckerberg what's he up to
lately uh stealing people's information
probably it's all gone
that old person app stole everyone's
information okay speaking yeah speaking
of that like there's this new
advertisement on TV in between my who
loose it's called a commercial yes
and it tripped me out guys I've been
freaking out about it wow it's it's got
it's a laptop by HP that's got a kill
switch on the side has anyone else well
it's got a camera kill switch so that
your laptop camera can never be watched
by anything else and I was like wait so
they're giving you the option to allow
people that's so then that is where my
brain went my brain went instantly so
all the other ones that don't have kill
switches like every [ __ ] computer in
my house is I got my tape on my dad and
that's all I have to live on mine too
but I was just like so it's a button
that's basically the tape and then I
just kept thinking like this is where
we've landed it's where we have to feel
better where how you have kill switches
for the laptop things that's crazy I
haven't seen that I it's like you know
the FBI's watching you but now you have
the option to opt out yeah no it's a
fake button and that's all I kept
thinking to is I was like that's a fake
button if I've ever seen one big red
button on your laptop click it just as a
flick and you're like what the [ __ ] it
says my cameras off but all I heard was
my insurance you know but I'm like I'm
just genuinely even the fact that they
were like you know I make people feel
better if there's a kill switch on the
side for the camera they felt like they
had control over this and other paranoia
and all I felt was oh god oh god this is
where we're at now but that's in I don't
like that at all yeah welcome to the
future grace well this I don't have an
Alexa I don't have a Google home I don't
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] I'll get an Alexa
but only because I just they're too cool
they dude she offers too much help and I
don't I want to struggle by myself I'm
just afraid too many conversations I
have by myself she's gonna say something
that's just gonna open my eyes what's
wrong with me well Mitchell okay I've
been noticing recently that you should
have more zinc in your diet the I have
full conversations with my dog that are
not you know healthy probably have
totally I talked at her like a human
that just has decided not to respond and
I keep on going before I came here I
completely sat megabyte down and tried
to explain to her again what a podcast
is how it works what I'm doing
daddy's gonna go do what I'm gonna do
when I get how I'm gonna come back it's
gonna be fine put ten dollars on the
table so she can order a pizza
sure and I'm like if there's no change
that I know you're lying
someone did ask any plans on adding to
the cat family if you know what if I all
of a sudden get like a great income I
would definitely get a bigger place and
get some cats that'd be so fun
how many cats I think my limit would be
two and a half - mm okay two and a half
is megabyte considered a half yeah
definitely megabytes a half
oh wait you shot a video with towner
recently right I did how'd you enjoy
Charles and Lady her hairless duo okay
so is Charles the one that has the crazy
hair yeah Charles is the one that looks
like a space alien so I definitely
thought that she has been cutting that
hair like that this whole time and
brought it up with her when I was there
I was like you're telling me this mother
[ __ ] grows like that like the lint
pile and like dryer I didn't know that
that she was like I thought she was like
trimming that cat's doing because she
was allergic to hair or something that
thing oh whoa like soft velvety both
cats are great they Derek they're
climbing all over me I was having a
great time but I genuinely when when I
was like so how long does it take to
like do this to this cat just like to
what now it's like cut the hair like
this all over look me free is like I
love ugly dogs so I did it and it sounds
like maybe just another aspect of this
world work so I can handle like shaving
her cat but I guess I never put it
together until just like that's what's
detail she said to my face and I said
and thought I was like of course what
she doesn't do that in my head there was
there was little shavers that she was
like not telling us she was making a
purposeful choice that present Charles
that way yes the but she first got
Charles for those you that don't know
Hannah Hart has two hairless cats
Charles was originally hairless yeah it
was he was
on hairless and I got used to him like
that and then he started to grow this
weird puffy stubbly stuff and I was like
she cheated on her I'm like this is even
more confusing than the hairless thing
this feels like someone that did some
like Rogaine but it grew in kind of
patchy it makes it an even crazier
looking at I loved it I loved it too and
that's why I genuine was like that's why
you got to keep up with it and stuff
like how did you do it i I know man it
was nuts Charles I don't think has ever
blinked in its entire life give me such
stress when I look it up it looks like
he's watching the world burn
Charles had this thing where he just
kept sitting or is he I think that he
the cat just kept like perching on my
shoulder and I was just like look I'm a
pirate that's crazy I love them okay
someone's no what was the moment you
realized oh [ __ ] I'm an adult
[Laughter]
mine was the first year out of college
on my step mom called me when I was in
Brooklyn and she was like did you pay
your taxes and I was like huh it was
like the week I was like I got a do what
now when Oh a while ago how do I do that
and I like just cried budget thing I
don't know I for me I think it was when
I was I mean it was like a fee it was
just like a few years ago when I was
like looking at pictures of people and I
was like yeah that kind of looks like me
and I was like that's a grown [ __ ]
person that means that you think you
look like like it was one of those
moments or it's like I've been looking
in the mirror but not really then when I
saw someone else who look like me I was
like that's an older person and then I
looked in the mirror and was like [ __ ]
it's the same person have you ever asked
for doppelgangers for people to send you
your doppelganger God no that sounds
terror I know I haven't done it I'm
fascinated you got to do it if you're
listening do it right now then Mitchell
all of his doppelgangers I don't even
know where I would start for you I don't
either I know I have a I have a thing to
do this afternoon maybe Leonardo
DiCaprio yeah maybe
mean to laugh like that but you know I
mean you did it's like I'm bears for you
know what's the worst job you've ever
had
that's a laugh out loud question good
mitzvahs only had one job I mean
entertainment yeah no I'd say the worst
the worst thing I ever did that I was
just like why did I do that
was I did this like series I did this
like little series on teaching you
things about the Internet and it was it
was too much voiceover was it supposed
to be sincere like real and it was just
like here's what a MOOC bang is and like
explaining it to you and it was like how
to's the internet it was just like this
thing new form wanted to do and I was
like I don't think this is a good idea
and that the view is very showed it uh
yeah but I was just like whatever I'll
do it cuz you guys want to but then I
realized that all the scripts I was like
oh I'm not saying this stuff out loud
this is all like a TR later and and I
hate I hate this see cuz it's not like
wasn't like fun ADR it was like can you
be more clear and I was like dang yeah
oh yeah when it's like I need to talk
any Nancy yes because the character was
1950s Oh yikes
so it was like a MOOC bang is when
someone sits in front of a computer and
they'd be like you pop there can we do
it again like oh okay yeah and that
makes you so self-conscious about you
talking yeah and like I would go home
and I was like I don't speak right yeah
low hello am i pronounciating
pronounciating yeah thanks correctly
that was definitely a project that I was
like oh man like I'm not like bummed
that I did it but I definitely was like
it's stressful it was yeah it was just
something that I there could have been
something else I did with that time that
was it would have been way cooler on
here - well meanwhile someone also asked
so working on your voice over career
gold god I wish I wish somebody would
give me a call my you're bad at ADR no
well the thing is though is it was like
it was ADR in like a commercial setting
when it's like and I was just talking
about this was strawberry 17 she just
said oh yeah that she's the voice of the
Pink Ranger in the new video games yeah
and I was just like that's my favorite
stuff is like a moding and having to
explain and voice acting yeah and voice
acting yes and that's the stuff that I
like like when anytime new form had me
doing that like you put me in a booth
and tell me that like you know I'm
running away yes that's the fun stuff
and like when I'm having to like the
more controlled like enunciation stuff
is just stressful yeah but when it was
like your the movie phone guy I was like
this is not what I that's not boys
acting this is just like this it was
just I don't know it just felt weird it
felt like I was like the voice behind a
documentary that I knew no one was gonna
watch I was like what am i doing well we
should just be putting music behind it's
like dude dude dude yeah and just have
text on screen or something yeah it's
fair you'll save money on my paycheck
whatever I have we can still put out you
know feelers and messages if anyone
needs some voiceover oh I I definitely
don't feel like that's over for me just
because I mean I'm still so young and
still so young a handful of comments
you've made it about your age counter
that [ __ ] yeah no I meant I mean I'm
still so young in this industry and
they're still I still am very very much
like I just set up my my own proper real
like pro mic at home and have been
crossing things and see ya I'm still
figuring it out so I don't I I got time
I wouldn't expect by now to be like oh
you haven't hurt me in eight things it's
like no no your voice box won't get
older like our faces do it's true you
have an even longer longevity in this
entertainment industry there we go long
as you don't [ __ ] with your voice box at
all I never will okay there we go
I actually heard a lot that was
impressive they didn't hurt it at all
hire me someone says tips for living on
your own for the first time
oh man buy a bunch of TP buy all the
toilet paper that you know I thought
you've been like an actual like TP I was
like that
what no that's a little if you already
got the apartment that seems to me yeah
you already have shelter no I
yeah yeah I talked about this in like a
like video when I first moved out like
years and years and years and years ago
where I just I had a moment the first
time I moved out I realized I ran out of
toilet paper and I and I instantly
screamed for my family to throw me some
and they weren't anyone was there and I
was like this is a video I have to warn
the world does everyone know this could
happen to them this could happen to you
so yeah I'm just like any any of that
stuff that you're like that's always in
the house go by it
yeah right now and then buy extra it
doesn't get into the house until you buy
it and put it in and I never thought
about that like my grandma just branch
bags someone's sneaking things at Fry's
like toilet paper was just limitless
trash bags limitless few tips I always
had a new toothbrush every month what
the [ __ ] is happening soothe pain yeah
now all of a sudden I'm like oh that's
gone yeah and I'm my responsibility and
I need that yeah also it turns you into
MacGyver when you do run out of what is
disposable how do i do i just shower
this off right is so [ __ ] real Oh
trust me my brain goes to 12 different
thousands especially I mean because you
think about that in like a public
restroom situation and when there's no
toilet paper in a public restroom should
be illegal for that to happen man I have
okay so the the roll the the tube I have
peeled that into three separate layers
so that it was just soft enough to be
like you guys are going down and I you
have no choice you know just just run
out and that's awesome you know what's
crazy is you'd think that piece would be
made out of something for that situation
but instead that piece is like the
biscuits box there's a biscuit thing
where you just burst it and it just kind
of is like one weird shape of hard paper
that's all it is and you're like great
this is gonna be how it goes today they
make paper towels that don't have a
toilet paper without the roll in the
middle so you know you're out when
you're out but I would love to have like
a secret little treasure roll that like
you can peel it apart and surprise it's
more toilet paper
yes that's what that's what I'm talking
about or we just make bigger rolls of
toilet paper look me and grace need big
that's what we're trying to say we need
a big thick we need a big attention
sharks we would like to present to you a
new idea it's called ultra paper and
what it is is it's for your toilet and
it's ultra okay this stuff does not
dissolve it Clark's toilets you can't
use it in your buildings but if you have
a newer building these things are twelve
by twelve it exists way Bridges Sherman
has a toilet paper roll where has more
toilet paper in the middle of the roll
Oh Charmin has the new forever roll ally
that won't go on forever give me this
look at that's not do you have to
probably get it round get an extra like
a holder yeah oh yeah you can't you can
get the starter kit it's a kit yeah I
didn't know I mean we're really living
in 2030 no toilet paper comes in kits
never how many emails Sherman had to get
further like I guess we got to make the
super roll phone oh my god it's ultra
soft oh it's up to a month yeah a
two-person household typically uses
about one roll per month they don't know
my digestive system gonna say that's not
me in a day I guess you guys eat well I
call them back I'm like hey I use your
big fat crazy roll in a week what do I
do now there's nothing to lose but the
roll holder is free when you buy three
rolls and you can easily return it for
any reason
oh this episode was brought to you by
Sherman big rolls big poops I need big
rolls well Sherman's got them do you are
you too afraid to go to a doctor to
control your gastrointestinal
terribleness well yeah I'd love to meet
the guy who's like guys you guys have
checked this out I just got the forever
roll you got a crap at my house later
yeah it's so sick it's also hilariously
large looking in that photo and there's
no real comparison to like what yeah
like a cartoon did go into someone's
like house during a party and that roll
was sitting in the bathroom I would lose
my mind
yeah I don't know if I'd be I think I
would be like in bed
first for them and then secretly like
jealous that I didn't have this I would
instantly just be like hey are you
leaking from somewhere hey you're always
eating to dry off are you okay I would
just come out and I'm like are you okay
I feel like we should talk okay
we're coming to the end Mitchell but
someone's no weapon of choice in the
zombie apocalypse which I think for now
would be the forever rule for me I could
TP so many houses and get away with it I
never have to buy more oh man zombie of
maybe just a zombie I think I'm just
gonna be that dude's got a zombie on a
leash that's like yeah get him yeah mom
we got one of you and he's around me and
in the city we ought to be that dude
who's like you find me and like Bill
Murray you know I'm talking about Bill
Murray in zombie land when he's like
when he's like yeah I just I just
decided to start painting my face like a
zombie and now I could do anything
anywhere that's what I would do that's
the I mean that's the right way I need
have a forever friend like you never be
alone I quit I know where to pick up my
my forever roll yeah are they find that
your Hilaire do zombies [ __ ] I don't
know but I would do is that like what
are the actual like body functions of a
zombie do they all just shut down like
do they throw up if they eat the wrong
thing do they have do they have like if
I become a zombie is my lactose issue
still pending I was just about to say
here's a comedy you ready it's a zombie
who finds out he has like allergies and
allergy again strange Oh
I mean cuz when you become a zombie I
guess all of your dietary restrictions
just like disappear too I mean we're
making facts about something that's not
real so this is true facts this is where
you come to not too deep for education
and nothing but facts also I would love
to see that comedy series of zombies
that just actually have real ailments
yeah he's like I can only get my protein
through other things it's honestly the
brain it just what a juice diet it just
hurts my stomach too much I have acid
reflux just meet the diarrhea
I'd love to see it zombies with
allergies yeah it's like the Big Bang
Theory but just zombies okay no I know
just about people with allergies no I'm
saying that's like that's how you would
set up the show that's like the show's
format where it would just be in front
of a live audience and they would just
be like talking to each other all the
time I don't know I just do that with
the Geico cavemen and I did not pan out
well but sharks I have a new idea for
you it's called zombies with allergies
it's coming to CBS this fall I'm very
excited Kelly cuoco is gonna be in it Oh
Mitchell this was fun yeah which is Chad
as always anything else to add no cool
that's why you come back month-to-month
your conversational skills are limitless
like that toilet paper
i-it's a forever it's a forever where
can people that don't know find you and
what you're up to if you want to give us
any hint spoilers so nuggets of what's
going on I've been working on just so
many like weird artsy videos yeah your
grandma looks real cool right now yeah
and I've been taking a lot of pictures
follow me on instagram subscribe to me
on live la ville live TV for the
weirdest stuff if you are even remotely
a little stoned you'll enjoy my videos
these days hell yeah and that's a great
way to pitch them I someone said it to
me at VidCon it was like that is genius
or I can't believe I've been calling
them art videos this whole day I should
just be calling them tripping videos I
feel like but there's a new era on
YouTube where everyone wants everyone to
get high and do things right used to be
like get drunk and do something and now
cuz I like tweeting out asking for a
video idea that the day and at like 80%
of it was like get high and buy stuff
get high and do your makeup and your us
it's great at that she nails it I would
just get high and it'd be a half hour of
me in silent paranoia staring into the
camera which isn't that different from
me sober when I make a video seeing what
I do is I'm getting high and then taking
footage that I love and being like how
can I turn this into something beautiful
how can I make it so that you see it the
way I see it that's close yeah I've been
uploading like I'd say for a month it's
been awesome and your animated stuff
like the flowers and stuff when you're
putting little faces on it I love
that [ __ ] yeah I've just been no I bet
literally I've been like oh all of my
rules
[ __ ] them great good for you yeah I mean
we're young and old at the same time you
still got time
what's the DFA thing it's like it's a -
too young to be no no no someone look
this up with DFA records too new to be
old too young to be dftba DFA or fire
yeah no it has someone that knows that
is screaming it right no it's like too
young to be yeah that's us
too old to be new too new to be classic
that's us
wow that sounds better than how I see
myself so thank you for that Mitchell
yeah appreciate it okay so check out
everything Mitchell's up to because it
changes constantly and I think it's a
it's a fun little treasure trove of
what's he gonna do next and I'm also on
that journey and I have no idea on that
note we'll see you guys next time on
another episode not you deep goodbyes
that wasn't an awkward ending was it no
very very shallow do you have a forever
or - boy - deep deep deep deep not too
deep as a production of grace Helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
Melissa Dumont's writing by Diane Kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]